hello and welcome to a brief clip from
this week's gamespot of Thrones if you'd
like to watch the full video head over
to youtube.com slash gamespot alright
cold hands so for years but readers have
been speculating about who it could be
so could obviously Benjen stark is the
the obvious choice the night's watchman
who went missing who's then come back as
cold hands there's also other names in
the mix like old like really old Nights
Watch members who have just gone missing
like I literally hundreds of years ago
it could be them but now it seems that
the showrunners so at least for the TV
show cold hands is benjamin star
in the book we know that he's definitely
member the Nights Watch because he's
dressed in black and he meets am Tolly
in the book at some point sitting calls
him brother again saying that he's
remember the Nights Watch so it's kind
of strange that he has been confirmed as
benjin because there was the thing I saw
where someone had found an original
manuscript of a dance of dragons and
they had editors notes written on them
and one of the editors notes was so cold
hands ears benjin ? and George wrote in
big red pen no like circled it so it
will be interesting to see if this is a
plot point they're gonna deviate on hmm
I mean previous to this hold the holder
stuff hasn't reaches finale in in the
books as it George has confirmed that
came from right so this would be the
first plot deviation right not really
like I think if it was a big character
reveal like sometimes characters could
change around right the reason I was
thinking is because we know benjin as a
character like we met him in season one
he's Ned's brother he took John to the
wall is it just convenience that he's
called hands I mean is part convenience
but also makes good sense like obviously
been genes unknown quantity he's like he
went missing for a period and he has
familiarity and has been in close
contact with the White Walkers so if it
was gonna be anyone it like he's the
best option I think and it kind of fits
the way the story is actually going it's
not like he's shoehorned in there
because obviously at the same time you
know brand is seeing the visions and a
lot of the visions are of his family
being killed which is something he
didn't really see because he wasn't
present but it might be a way of kind of
reinforcing his family kind of
connection again yeah to remind him that
he is you know a relative of benjin to
kind of create that connection maybe as
a replacement for at all I mean how did
they've always been talked quite close
play he needs someone who he can rely on
again and for that person like I think
the best person is his uncle Benjen
that's interesting and she's saying that
reinforcing the family time because
especially now the benches like oh yeah
the three-eyed Raven is you and last
week the three rappers like oh I'm
training you to be my replacement it's
as if bran was his own entity rather
than being bran stark he's becoming a
three-eyed Raven yeah this all seen it
makes for the best storytelling as well
because if it was some old dude it's
been missing a hundred years ago who
saved brownie be like why do I yeah well
yeah and there's a lot more kind of
gravitas to it being benjin because
obviously his brother's been killed all
of his family have been killed so he's
got this real kind of need to help his
nephew and kind of see things through
and get rid of the White Walkers and you
know who knows where they could go on
from there they go conquer the world and
obviously since he's half white Walker
and the White Walkers are trapped north
of the wall because of the wars magic
yeah maybe he can now come south again
yeah yeah and like imagine that reunion
with with John like yeah oh by the way I
died once and came back to life oh hi
uncle Benjen you're half a white Walker
yeah like that's that's Edison like a
supernatural family stuff going on yeah
he could be the key to defeating you
know the wild walkers he's part you know
he's got one point each world and he
could like come in between and be like
the key to figuring out how to bring
them down once and for all and he knows
what he's doing he's fighting them
because i used the the flaming yellow
and the the change sides to smash
exactly bone man so I mean which kind of
Steve's hello you know it feeds into the
burn them all kind of thing yeah
you